[Música]
o jovem sabe quem é
o corpo de armando província tudo de bom
não cai nossa sã do gol
[Música]
não ver
pensando no dinheiro
dançando forró
sandy buscando faro
é um homem dos zumbis a
i e ii
eu contei lhe restou
o almoço
amor não tem tempo não entusiasmar mas o
coração não possa voltar a ensaiar
endereço
o novo carro
não generoso com faro
[Música]
uma jovem em 28 e não sabe o que quer de
mim
e mesmo com falta de jeito ou prestação
não é nem science
em seguida volta a olhar o mundo mas
quero deixar só quero ainda fazer tudo
eu sabia o endereço pois quem falo da
bancada
teresa
tanto faz
o deputado
não
mas com falta
[Música]
[Aplausos]
obrigada pessoa via pés ou engana aqui
né e leva já mais calma aí é bom então
faltou atenção com isso é uma pequena
amostra criar agradecer o convite da tv
que passar aqui primeira canção do caixa
mas não tem preço
vou agora para a segunda que chama a
nossa atenção ou eu sou a via está
escalada é meu parto ou mesmo ajudando
conhece e está ótimo pra mim e queria já
só sóbis ataque àqueles dia 13 de
dezembro estava estreando na sala 2 da
casa da música
se quiserem vir eu não gostar sozinho
está muito mais bem acompanhada e tem
dois convidados que é uma aprende ou e
joão só acho que vai ser um bom concerto
[Música]
dondo mundundu tudo mundo tomando mundo
do dub
só estou querendo essa é a nossa senhora
do ó
mas o carinho pra vocês
dodô mandou todo mundo cantando não todo
mundo quer viver esse momento os
voluntários a 2 teve london london
num estado foi uma caminhada
tudo fora à espera de um lugar de toda
essa calma fugir do nosso momento nem
que gritava que era das mais feliz
quando não me amar
já não sei quem já não sei que só sai se
alguém que nos mundo não sair também já
não sei que só sei amar em que nojo do
do mundo mudou
don don don com 11 foi permitir isto e
aproximar essa é na muralha senhor há
como deixar de ser promessa e levá
quando eu te daiane já não saem já não
sei que só sai à quinta no google não
sai em casa não sei que só sai de lá nem
telur
[Música]
o mundo osim é teu amigo
já
[Música]
ninguém
já não sou eu quem já não sei que só
sangue selvagem carlos tudo não sai quem
já não sei que isso não sei que o blog
entender quando cheguei por aí só tem e
terá o campeão
[Música]
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]